imagine a scientist who wants to send a
robot to explore in a far away place
a place whose geography might be
completely unknown and perhaps
inhospitable
now imagine that instead of first
designing that robot and sending it off
in the hope that it might be suitable
instead she sends a robot producing
technology
that figures out what kind of robot is
needed once it arrives
builds it and then enables it to
continue to evolve to adapt to its new
surroundings
it's exactly what my collaborators and i
are working on
a radical new technology which enables
robots to be created
reproduce and evolve over long periods
of time
a technology where robot design and
fabrication becomes a task for machines
rather than humans
robots are already all around us in
factories in hospitals in our home
but from an engineer's perspective
designing a shelf-stacking robot or a
roomba to clean our home is relatively
straightforward
we know exactly what they need to do
and we can imagine the kind of
situations they might find themselves in
so we design with this in mind
but what if we don't want to send that
robot to operate in a place that we have
little or even no knowledge about
for example cleaning up legacy waste
inside a nuclear reactor where it's
unsafe to send humans
mining for minerals deep in a trench at
the bottom of the ocean
or exploring a far away asteroid
how frustrating would it be if the human
designed robot that had taken years to
get to the asteroid suddenly found it
needed to drill a hole to collect a
sample or clamber up a cliff but it
didn't have the right tools or the right
means of low promotion to do so
if instead we had a technology that
enabled the robots to be designed and
optimized in situ
in the environment in which they need to
live and work then we could potentially
save years of wasted effort and produce
robots that are uniquely adapted to the
environments that they find themselves
in
so to realize this technology we've been
turning to nature for help
all around us we see examples of
biological species
that have involved smart adaptations
that enable them to thrive in a given
environment
for example in the cuban rainforest we
find vines that have evolved leaves that
are shaped like human designed satellite
dishes
these leaves direct bats to their
flowers by amplifying the signals that
the bats send out therefore improving
pollination
what if we could create an artificial
version of evolution
that would enable robots to evolve in a
similar manner as biological organisms
i'm not talking about biomimicry a
technology which simply copies what's
observed in nature
what we're hoping to harness is the
creativity of evolution
to discover designs that are not
observed here on earth
that human engineer might not have
thought of or even be capable of
conceiving
in theory this evolutionary design
technology could operate completely
autonomously in a far away place
but equally it could be guided by humans
just as we breed plants for qualities
such as drought resistance or taste the
human robot breeder could guide
artificial evolution to producing robots
with specific qualities for example the
ability to squeeze through a narrow gap
or perhaps operate at low energy
this idea of artificial evolution
imitating biological evolution using a
computer program to breed better and
better solutions to problems over time
isn't actually new
in fact artificial evolution algorithms
operating inside a computer have been
used to design everything from tables to
turbine blades
back in 2006 nasa even sent a satellite
into space with a communication antenna
that been designed by artificial
evolution
but evolving robots is actually much
harder than evolving passive objects
such as tables because robots need
brains as well as bodies
in order to to make sense of the
information that in the world around
them and translate that into appropriate
behaviors
how do we do it
surprisingly
evolution only needs three ingredients
a population of the individuals which
exhibit some physical variations
a method of reproduction in which
offspring inherits some traits from
their parents and occasionally acquire
new ones via mutation
and finally a means of natural selection
so we can replicate these three
ingredients to evolve robots using a
mixture of hardware and software
the first task is to design a digital
version of dna
that is a digital blueprint that
describes the robot's brain its body its
sensory mechanisms and its means of
locomotion
using a randomly generated set of these
blueprints we can create an initial
population of 10 or more robots to kick
start this evolutionary process
we've designed a technology that can
take the digital blueprint and turn it
into a physical robot without any need
for human assistance
for example it uses a 3d printer to
print print the skeleton of the robot
and then an automated assembly arm like
you might find in a factory to add any
electronics and moving parts
including a small computer that acts as
a brain
and to enable this brain to adapt to the
new body of the robot we send every
robot produced
to an equivalent of a kindergarten a
place where where the newborn robot can
refine its motor skills almost like a
small child would
to mimic natural selection we score
these robots on the ability to conduct a
task
and then we use these scores to
selectively decide which robots get to
reproduce
the reproduction mechanism mixes the
digital dna of the chosen parent robots
to create a new blueprint for a child
robot
that inherits some of the
characteristics from its parents but
occasionally also exhibit some new ones
and by repeating the cycle of selection
and reproduction over and over again
we hope that we can breed successive
generations of robots where just like is
often observed in biological evolution
each generation gets better than the
last
with the robots gradually optimizing
their form and the behavior to the task
and the environment that they find
themselves in
now although this can all take place in
a time frame that's much faster than
biological evolution which sometimes
takes thousands of years
it's still relatively slow in terms of
the time frames we might expect in our
modern world to design and produce an
artifact
it's mainly due to the 3d printing
process which can take more than four
hours per robot depending on the
complexity and the shape of the robot
but we can give our artificial
evolutionary process a helping hand to
reduce the number of physical robots
that we actually need to make
we create a digital copy of every robot
produced inside a simulation in a
computer
and we allow this virtual population of
robots to evolve
now
it's quite likely that the simulation
isn't a very accurate representation of
the real world
but it has an advantage that it enables
models of robots to be created and
tested in seconds rather than hours
so using this simulated technology we
can quickly explore the potential of a
wide range of robot types of different
shapes and sizes of different sensory
configurations and quickly get a rough
estimate of how useful each robot may be
before we physically make it
and we predict that by allowing a novel
form of breeding in which a physical
robot can breed with a one of its
virtual cousins
then the useful traits that have been
discovered in simulation will quickly
spread into the physical robot
population where they can be further
refined in situ
it might sound like science fiction
but actually there's a serious point
while we expect the technology that i've
just described to be useful in designing
robots for example to work in situations
where it's unsafe to send humans or to
help us pursue our scientific quest for
exoplanetary exploration
there's some more pragmatic reasons why
we should consider artificial artificial
evolution
as climate change gathers pace it's
clear that we need a radical rethink to
our approach to robotic design here on
earth in order to reduce their
ecological footprint
for example creating new designs of
robot built from sustainable materials
that operate at low energy
that are repairable and recyclable
it's quite likely that this new
generation of robots won't look anything
like the robots that we see around us
today
but that's exactly why artificial
evolution might help
discovering novel designs by processes
that are unfettered by the constraints
that our own understanding of
engineering science imposes on the
design process
thank you